welcome back to the iced coffee hour
this is daniel mack so far this podcast
i would say has made fifty thousand
dollars not including sponsors no wow
that's under yeah that's very rare we
get under guests significantly under oh
significant
and fifty one dollars 225
fifty nine cents okay because the brand
sponsors i feel like are what pull a lot
of it is that not true it is yeah the
brands definitely help us out a lot
thank you brands but
yeah thank you so much for coming on
daniel we really appreciate it you guys
i'm sure if you're on tik tok you've
seen anywhere really anyway gosh you
show up everywhere like he can't get rid
of you man i'm on facebook i'll scroll
youtube shorts i'll scroll instagram
i'll scroll you come up for me every
like 10 tick tocks there's one of you oh
gosh i hope that's a good thing yeah i
hope so what do you do for a living
what do you do uh uh and then they give
off an answer how did you get started
doing this and how many how many views
and and followers did you get so far
from doing this like across the platform
it's going to be more than like a
monthly view count across all platforms
i don't know i mean it's got to be crazy
it's in the billions
just crossed a billion views um that's
youtube alone
talks a couple billion and now though
i'd say i think i have like 17 or 18
million followers across all platforms
so it's really crazy because i mean i i
was working in finance prior i graduated
college freshly out of college um and i
moved to dallas texas to do a job in
finance like financial advising for
charles schwab the brokerage firm and i
had never done content before i like
wasn't trying to be a content creator i
was like content creation is not for me
i was gonna work like a desk job in
finance for the rest of my life and be
happy doing that but then i just filmed
a video because i had an idea over the
summer it was like
where like how are these people getting
these cars like and i wasn't even the
biggest car guy is the thing people
assume i'm like the wizard of all things
cars and now i'm really good but um at
the time i was just kind of a moderate
fan you'd say so i filmed the video um
and it went crazy my first post ever on
tick tock had like 20 million views in a
day and then i had a million followers
on tick tock within a week explain what
that video was where was it filmed okay
so i was in dallas texas i was with my
friend grant um and we were in like kind
of a fancy hotel area literally hunting
for cars because we came up with the
concept and i saw a ferrari just pulled
up at a hotel so i asked the guy hey
what do you do for a living and he says
i don't even remember now something like
i'm a doctor or something like that and
then we see another guy he's in an audi
r8 and he just drops you know some
general life advice but then we see a
guy in a lamborghini huracan and he
looks really like fancy or just
interesting so he pulls out of the hotel
and we start tracking him down the road
and go like eight blocks we roll up to
his window and he looks over us with
shades on after i asked the question
he's like i sell drugs and that was the
video that like popped it off and i
didn't even expect it at the time but i
post that and it just went absolutely
crazy i had no idea i was refreshing my
screen like what the hell and all my
friends and family were like didn't even
know it was me for like a month or two
because i never showed my face so how
did you evolve from that so you
obviously knew pretty quickly like
immediately you had a good concept so
what did you do after you're just like
let's keep repeating this yeah i mean
people say like find your niche on
tiktok which i think is really true but
i'm like basically i was surprised that
i thought i had like two or three videos
with it you know i thought like after
you know one or two people would stop
caring but i think people are always
gonna be interested in like how to get
wealthy obviously but i started
branching out into other stuff so i
started doing yacht content like i'd go
to miami i'd like break into these yacht
yards in miami like where you're not
allowed to be with some of these like
really really rich people um and i'd ask
them like on their ships like hey what
do you do for a living and sometimes
they invite me on and we go like on a
yacht party or something like that like
miami's crazy like that but uh we
started doing like cribs like um cribs
like mtv cribs and we'd go check out
people's like 40 or 50 million dollar
mansions and i'd ask them what they do
and um they'd tell me and we'd check out
their cool collections and interviewing
people it's such a broad like phrase
like what do you do for a living that
now i can sit down with like people that
are in various fields and i can ask them
how do you get wealthy and it just keeps
on evolving essentially yeah that's
incredible now how often is it that you
get like a really negative reaction it's
funny i just posted a video of all the
negative reactions i've ever gotten yeah
that one's funny um i'd say it's rare
though like it's every i don't know one
in one in ten maybe less like maybe one
to five percent of the time it's
normally not at like a car show i'll go
to car shows and everyone's like they
know that i'm going to be there or like
they're in the car community so they
want to show off their stuff but i'll go
to like rodeo drive in beverly hills and
you'll get some wonky characters out
there um but sometimes people just like
yell at me and i used to not like it but
now i love it because it's even better
content right yeah what's some of the
best advice you've gotten from these
people well i mean and you probably love
this one but real estate number one i
mean people ask me like what's the most
common
uh job that people are in
and it's always real estate commercial
real estate for the real ballers out
there that like have you know like
yachts and whatnot they're always in
like huge properties um but in general
real estate get into that it's never too
early to buy a property regardless of
what the market's doing people tell me
that all the time
a lot of people are in like various
industries like tech
that's kind of where you see like the
new money mclaren drivers not to
stereotype certain car owners but tech
for sure um and then you get like the
basic like follow your dreams kind of
people that don't really know what to
say um but i'd say investing is
obviously number one and i kind of knew
that with my background a little bit but
everyone invests that has this kind of
money like you literally can't be
wealthy by just having like a salary is
what i've learned and then also owning
your own business is the other big one
so i'd say like real estate own your own
business because there's only so much
money you can make like
as a doctor even like you're capped out
at what like 300k a year or something
like that three to five depending on it
or if you
yeah yeah yeah so how long did you do
the financial advisory stuff until you
decided to quit that and do tick tock
and like content creation full time um
so i was doing it for
nine months i think so i wasn't like a
master or anything like that i've been
fascinated with finance my whole life so
i was always interested in it but um i
was doing that job for like nine months
um and it was awful when i was doing it
because not because of the job itself i
was really interested in it and people
will be like
um hey like good thing you got out of
that desk job i actually really liked it
i thought it was cool um and i'm
interested in the stock market and stuff
like that but i was basically from the
start of the job also simultaneously
doing tick tocks and whatnot so like i'd
finish work i'd do like a normal nine to
five
and then right after work i would
immediately jet on over to like some
populated like wealthy area like a mall
or whatnot and then on the weekends i
would fly out to la because i didn't
live there yet um so i would basically
be working like 100 hour weeks because
after work i would be editing or
reaching out to people or doing like
brand deal stuff and then on the
weekends i was filming non-stop while
also doing the regular nine to five so
it was quite the grind and at some point
i i remember i was filming with paris
hilton in in la while still doing this
normal job and i woke up that morning
and was just like i'm quitting my day
job like i was just with paris hilton i
got back at 8 a.m or you know late in
the night and i just woke up and was
like this is it i'm putting in my two
weeks which was really scary yeah were
you making more money on tick tock at
that point yes yeah i was pretty
conservative with it like a lot of
people are like hey like um you know
it's pretty stupid to move out to la and
you it's like the city of broken dreams
essentially like people go out there to
do acting and whatnot and they fail but
i was making like i think double my um
annual income at the time and i had like
seven or eight million followers on tick
tock at the time so i really could have
quit earlier i think but i didn't want
to be that guy that like moves out there
and then
has to move back or you know what's the
job what did your co-workers think about
this they know yeah they knew yeah i
kind of had to keep it under wraps a
little at the beginning um you had to
declare the income to your job but i was
like a little late on that
um and they were just like gobsmacked
like they a lot of people didn't know it
was me because i didn't i didn't show my
face in videos for like six months so
even my fan like friends basically were
like i see this daniel mac name popping
up here and it matches your voice like
is this you um and i just had to be like
yeah it's me and i started showing my
face a little more but everyone's
shocked do they now did trump have have
an issue with you having like a presence
outside of them couldn't that be a
liability if you did something and then
they're like well he works at charles
schwab no definitely yeah i mean it was
uh they were really good with it though
um i had a really great boss at the time
i think it could have gone way
differently in any other circumstance
but um they knew about it but it was
getting like hairy at the end there so
yeah which office was it um it was over
and it was north of dallas oh okay the
uh frisco or now plano office okay got
it okay uh but at the time we were work
from home so i never actually went into
the brand new facility ever can you say
about how much you were making right at
the time of quitting from both sources
yeah yeah um uh for the first is a
two-year program so it's like you're
getting your brokerage licenses and
whatnot so you weren't making a lot at
the store until you actually became a
full-fledged advisor but i think it was
around 55 or 50. so like just kind of
standard out of college job um
it would have amped up though so the
thing is i always want to do advising
that's why it was kind of a difficult
decision and i think out of like once
you're two years out or so with your own
book you'd be making like around six
figures or maybe slightly under at the
start so that was something i considered
i was like well this is what i want to
do long term for 40 years
what's a little payoff here quitting my
job for a couple years potentially
but on tick tock i think i was making
well what really happened actually was i
i got my first snapchat check in the
mail um and that was
20 000
just off of two videos it was probably
my highest one of my highest paid videos
at the time but um at the time i just
expected it to be like a couple thousand
like two thousand dollars i remember
getting the email i was sitting in my
apartment on the phone with my mom
actually just talking about like my job
and whatnot i open up the snapchat email
and i see like uh invoice or whatever to
me for twenty thousand two hundred
dollars something along those lines and
i just was like this is a mistake like
this can't be can't be accurate so i
re-read it and that was with a 50 cut
from snapchat so originally it was like
40 000 i generated them in ad revenue
and then after this it was 20. and i was
like oh like i've done two videos this
month and it did this much in revenue um
i'm quitting my job and then i went to
vegas or la the next week and that was
snapchat spotlight that wasn't like the
actual tiles no it was um my show on
spot on snapchat not spotlight i missed
the train on that oh wow yeah people
could have made a killing on there i
know yeah people were reposting my
videos on spotlight and making like
millions of dollars and i didn't even
know at the time yeah so for those that
don't know snapchat launched this
program to try to like have a tick tock
type competitor where it was like a feed
and you could post on there and they had
a budget it was one million dollars was
it per week per day at the beginning oh
my gosh a million dollars per day that
they were allocating towards the the
highest viewed creators so people were
repurposing your content and then making
like crazy slimy shady people made
millions like uh cam casey's um yeah
he's like their case study essentially i
think he made like three million dollars
off of like 10 videos or something on
spotlight yeah yeah but first we gotta
thank our sponsor ftx us now unless
you've been living under a rock you
probably know that crypto's been taking
a bit of a plunge lately and maybe that
means it's a good time to buy and if
you're considering doing so there's not
a better place than ftx yep ftx is
trusted by millions of users to buy sell
track and trade both crypto and nfts all
in one place with fees that are 85 lower
than the top competitors all you got to
do is select what you want to buy how
much of it you want to buy how often you
want to buy it and then you swipe right
and you're done and you get free crypto
on every single trade you make over ten
dollars wait did you mention something
about how often you want to buy are you
saying that there's like an automatic
investing feature on ftx where you can
just select weekly bi-weekly or monthly
where you can automatically invest money
yeah they just take care of it for you
it's incredibly easy unlike other crypto
exchanges they charge super hefty fees
when you're trading crypto how nasty is
that yeah it's so gross but with ftx
guys there are no fees whatsoever when
you trade crypto and nfts okay graham
just went to go clean out his fish tank
but i just want to mention they're soon
launching ftx stocks and they're going
to be an all-in-one inclusive app where
you can trade stocks crypto and nfts
with no fees so if you guys haven't
already downloaded it you should
definitely do so with the link down
below hey what i miss oh nothing but you
know what's not nothing you could get
all the way up to a hundred dollars for
the free crypto when you sign up for ftx
us down below in the description with
their link trade crypto and nfts with no
fees whatsoever with ftx with the link
down below in the description and now
let's get back to the podcast how do you
go from filming on your phone to then
meeting all these celebrities i mean
it's
dms on instagram is how i started out so
like i there were a couple people that
were really cool at the start when i had
like low follower count like low but
like a couple million on tick tock so
like i would just dm them out of the
blue um and this is for like later in
the game when i was doing more skits so
i originally was running up to people
like on rodeo drive like giannis like
the nba player i just got him in a
random video jason derulo i just
literally got him at a gas station that
was random i thought that was planned no
not not jason rules so some of the skits
are like
i want them i want people to know their
skits but some of these celebrities i'll
literally put like hashtag skit and
people be like this is fake and i'm like
yeah they're playing a part here but
some of the beginning ones that i were
doing were all legit with the
celebrities yeah that jason derulo one
it's like who just sees jason derulo at
a gas station yeah but did he know you
from tiktok uh i assume so yeah i mean
he was in tarzana when we filmed it um
and we were out there shooting um kind
of like a real estate like crib style
video we pulled over to get gas and
jason rulo was like his house is by
there yeah and he was in a green
hurricane so like we pulled off you know
essentially to go check it out and jason
gorilla is just chilling there but he
must have known i think he's just
chilling but let's say but how
nerve-wracking was that for you to go up
to jason derulo and say hey what do you
do for a living dude i didn't even know
if it was him at the very start uh but
it was crazy with some of these
celebrities i've met like i've done what
do you say he said you just said i'm
jason to rule for a living
thank you seriously yeah yeah
yeah that's a boss man when you just say
your name you're like oh okay i get it
he's one of the coolest guys we filmed
another follow-up like skit with him in
saudi arabia um and the man is probably
one of the most genuine like a-listers
you can ever meet like he's also really
tuned in with like finance yes investing
and all that kind of stuff yeah yeah we
communicated briefly uh actually it was
like 20 minutes where he he wanted uh he
wanted to do something in the finance
space online and uh one of my opinion on
that i was like the entire time star
struck just to be like he's calling i
dropped everything oh he called you yeah
he called me oh yeah it's like he's
calling right now
oh yeah yeah i mean somebody says so
nervous yeah it's like we've done like
helen mirren for a brand deal and like
richard branson like logan paul like
people like that and you're just like
okay like so don't be nervous are people
reaching out to you at this point being
like hey do a video or i'm trying to
promote something yeah i mean all the
time um it's just like a fine line
between letting people know like i don't
want people i don't want to do too many
of them because i don't want people to
think that my videos are like all fake
and stuff like that so like that's why
i'm like i make it apparent where i'm
like if we're doing something with a
celebrity i want people to know it's
like a skit
um but then sometimes you just run into
them you know out of the blue especially
in la it's crazy do you worry that there
might uh
you might have challenges long term with
the same format oh definitely yeah i
mean people are like do you think you
can do this forever i don't i'm not like
stupid i feel like there's no way that
the trend could keep up for years and
years i'm surprised it's kept up this
long i think people are just genuinely
fascinated with
like how to acquire wealth but i think
it's obviously i need to adapt and
change and do different stuff kind of
like what i've been saying with like
houses cars all things luxury
essentially but i also want to move more
into the investing sphere as well and
really like sit down with people and
find out like really like what do you do
for a living and like how did you get
this car or this house in a way that
like a tick tock can't actually
encapsulate like yeah right so your tick
tocks are mostly entertainment value
like you go up to people that are
driving these expensive cars ask them
what they do for a living and that
doesn't really provide like how much
insight as so as to like how they got to
where they are right but didn't aren't
you starting something where you can go
more long-form with some of the people
you're asking and you can talk about
like the actual process of becoming an
anesthesiologist or like a singer yeah
yeah exactly um it's more long-form con
i call it kind of mid-form content i
don't know if that's a real word but
like
five to six minute um video and podcast
style like audio video um i have it on
my snapchat so essentially where i sit
down with people sometimes i've been
more lewd you know we've had like an
only fans model on there but it is
interesting stuff like the only fans
industry in general is like there's
managers going on and there's like a lot
of stuff on the back on the back end
that people wouldn't expect yeah um and
it's kind of like a you know just a
monster empire that people don't really
realize so just cool interesting
occupations that you wouldn't expect but
then also anesthesiologist doctor like
really what is your path to getting to
this point that's what i want to do more
of is the more of the long you would do
so well if you asked somebody what do
you do for a living and then a doctor
can you give me five minutes of your
time just to talk about this and just
like an impromptu interview on the
street i don't think like a fancy
podcast set up or anything like that
just on the street with a mic just back
and forth five minutes i think would do
so well or in the car with them yeah you
driving in the car with them and they're
just telling you their life story i
think that would do so well because it's
like you're picking a random person off
the street and hearing their story yeah
it's not like filtered it's just like
whatever they say it's like raw yeah
right we've thought about doing that
with people in in cars and whatnot um i
mean it's kind of like comedians and
cars getting coffee but like the actual
like more serious version of that like
i'm in their lambo i got them in a video
maybe previously or whatnot like let's
drive around in their car that you saw
them originally in and let's find out
like the real like details on what they
did but i think that's a really good
idea just i'm outside a hospital and
someone's in like scrubs and i'm like
give me the real like uh i think just so
well you know what who did that uh i did
it great was deadmau5 where it was uh
what was it he took people on his
mclaren and would go and get coffee with
them or go to mcdonald's with them and
just him having a conversation as they
drive to mcdonald's or it was like a
fast food player tim hortons uh because
they're in canada and then they drive
back oh it was so good they were like 30
minutes and it was just him just
unfiltered you see the guy getting in
the car and they just drive oh it's
really cool i think if you did something
like that it would do incredibly well it
sounds like a really good idea yeah also
another thing to consider is do you know
like the tick tock salary transparent
street yes yeah they they came out and
they exploded like in the past month i
don't even know how many followers
it's like 800k or so 750. but every
single video that they post just pops
off and it's basically this girl that
travels to different places and she goes
to people what do you do for a living
and how much money do you make and she
just does it over and over and over
again and people just like eat it up on
tick tock and i think if you could
somehow incorporate also like revealing
people's incomes like for example you
see someone like a benty bentley and you
go up to them oh what do you do oh i'm a
doctor how much do you make and then
else do that i'll have to do people lie
i think a lot of people have seen the
videos and they have like these because
some of the responses are insane like
and people are like okay this is like
there's no way they actually do that i
think a lot of them are expecting like
me to maybe come up to them at some
point i mean people will be driving
around in like la and they say that
they've had like 30 people walk up to
them and ask them the questions so
that's why people go oh you're the guy
or like are you the guy because i don't
show my face always so they're like is
this another person coming up to me or
is it like the real person that started
it so yeah and it's happened to me
before like i've been driving i've had
like rental cars in miami or la for the
day and i'll be driving and i'll be like
at a stoplight and people will roll down
like their windows and be like hey what
do you do for a living and i'm like i'm
the one that does that thing and they're
like what the hell it's it's pretty cool
yeah so what do you drive i drive right
now a tesla model three which i kind of
anger some car people but i just ordered
a porsche gt4 car it'll be here in
september looking forward to bringing it
out on some canyons how much did that
cost you are you getting at it uh
sticker i think so yeah from porsche
dallas shout out porsche dallas but um
uh they uh basically it was like a seven
month wait uh or like 50k over like 100k
over to get it from anywhere else but um
i think they're pulling uh for me
essentially if i do some kind of promo
and show it off and whatnot but yeah i
mean i wanted to get a car
because i'm kind of you know i feel like
me and you were pretty similar in that
front where i didn't want to get
something that was like crazy out of
reach at the moment but i still needed
to get something that i could bring
around to like car shows and i was like
the car it's a respectable car yeah it's
like an investment too to get a car like
that i feel like i can't be driving
around like a model 3 forever as like
the guy that's filming all these videos
with cars and you could daily it if you
really wanted to drive it you could
drive that thing like 30 000 miles no
problems at all yeah what's your
favorite car that you have uh the tesla
roadster oh yeah that's your favorite
car favorite car you drive like bar
what i thought you were gonna say the no
no no no the tesla i'll take the tesla
out
way more than i'll ever take the gt out
really yeah oh yeah
it's the original that's the that one is
a 2010. okay i mean tesla's just drive
like
they get a lot of hate because people
are just love them so much because they
won't stop talking about them but it's
because they're so good like i'm
obsessed with my model 3. i noticed
you're also wearing that watch
now i remember seeing like when that
video came out you went up to a guy in a
fancy car what do you remember what car
it was it was a audi r8 in red yeah yeah
and you went up to him you're like all
right what do you do for living he's
like i have a watch dealership or
something right yes and then he brings
you to the dealership that he owns and
he gives you a watch yes it's one of my
best stories actually i'll tell you um
so it's this guy timepiece gentleman uh
he's in dallas and he's like a watch
broker basically i think he lives in
nelly now i get him in a video it's like
my fourth video i've ever filmed or
maybe third like one of my first initial
shots and i just say hey what do you do
for a living he's like i'm a watch
broker and then he shouts out his
instagram and normally now i wouldn't
add that portion with the shout out
because people would think it's like a
paid post like today i probably wouldn't
have done it but back then i remember i
get on the phone with my roommate and
he's like yeah just leave it in like
maybe something cool happened to you and
i was like okay fine um and then i post
the video and a day later i get like
tagged in a bunch of stuff and i still
don't have like really any followers but
this is on instagram so i had like no
followers on instagram at the time and
everyone's like pointing me to go to his
page and on his page is him holding a
rolex bag and it's like everyone get
daniel's attention i want him to give
him a gift for shouting me out so i'm
like okay there's no way this man's
about to give me a free rolex for just
shouting him out in a video and the
video did decent it got a couple million
views which is solid marketing but i'm
like okay let's find out what's
happening so the next day i meet up with
this guy after work um he gives me a
roll at this rolex it's a datejust can i
see it yeah take a look 41 millimeter i
think they go for like 12 000 now or so
jubilee band all that kind of stuff and
it's a great color oh
i l you know what's funny i got the uh
almost the same thing oh really yeah
it's a different uh
different dial oh the same size i think
mine's a little bit smaller
yeah mine is a different bracelet yeah
yeah yours is a smaller yeah so the
oyster bracelet yeah it's even more
expensive too so i'm surprised he like
because the the bezel it's like a fluted
bezel yeah it's a white gold yeah yeah
here you go jack he balled out on it wow
and then he filmed the video and he
posted it and it got him so much more
business by posting it like this guy's
like a genius that he said he sold like
a hundred watches because of the video
wow i believe it though yeah
when did you post the video what year uh
this was given give me like a rough it
was literally like two weeks after my
first video so it was like mid-september
of 2020 2020 yeah okay so the watch
market was going crazy then and so you
posted it at the right time just as the
market was taking off and everyone was
buying watches like that and he was in
the right spot at the right time
combined with your uh promotion in a way
just not even thinking about it yeah i
had no clue yeah
let me post this video yeah but first we
gotta thank our sponsor nordvpn graham i
was at the airport recently and it
looked like my laptop got this cool new
feature i got all these ads that started
popping up and it said someone was
collecting all my data for me that's not
a cool feature jack you really got to
make sure to secure your network and
make sure your data is protected
thankfully today's sponsor nordvpn has
the fastest and easiest way that you
could do that nordvpn is extremely easy
to use all it takes is one click and
you're connected not only is it super
easy to connect but they actually have
the fastest speeds out of all vpns and i
can personally attest to this i've been
using nordvpn for over two years now my
favorite part about nordvpn is their new
threat protection feature threat
protection blocks pop-up ads and web
trackers and when you click on any url
they will scan it and block it if it's a
malicious one another really cool
feature about nordvpn is you can change
your location because on netflix certain
countries block out certain shows or
movies but you can just change your
location with the vpn to wherever it is
allowed and you can watch any movie or
any tv show that netflix has from
wherever and that honestly guys is a
feature i've actually personally used so
get an exclusive nordvpn deal today
using the link down below in the
description or going to nordvpn.com
iced coffee to get started today you can
get a huge discount off your nordvpn
plan plus one whole additional month for
free it's risk free with nord's 30-day
money-back guarantee guys it's my
favorite vpn it's the best out there
definitely check it out with that link
down below in the description again the
link is down below in the description to
get started today and now with that said
let's get back to the podcast have you
seen much like external benefit from
approaching a bunch of really wealthy
people and asking what they do i mean
just crazy connections like every single
person that i interact with is wealthy
like because they're all just driving
these crazy cars some of them i mean i
don't know a couple of them are rentals
probably i've asked people and they've
been like yeah this is a rental um so
they're honest in that fashion but uh
just like the crazy connections like
i'll go to i'll be like i know people in
every city now like if i go to miami
like there's people there that have
yachts and they're like come hang out
and do this thing i feel like if i
started a business um i would have a lot
of like wealthy people that could have
maybe helped pool me money or i could
work with um i don't see myself going
back to like a nine to five any time
soon it'd probably be like my own
business with people that i've met that
are wealthy and i'm curious if you could
put a price tag on uh on your
connections like when you think of your
network and how much that's worth
gosh what do you think man if you were
to like buy that network someone said 10
million bucks 20 million dollars like
the people that you know at this point
are worth more than you would probably
ever make just just having those
connections and having those friendships
it's crazy yeah i mean like it's
i got to do something with it though
because people tell me that all the time
yeah oh you have all these crazy
connections and i'm like i don't know
what to do with them yet not like you
know i use friends or whatnot as like
connections only like uh but yeah i feel
like in the next you know a couple of
years or something some of these people
i've met will come to like be really
cool either business partners or
life advice people or whatnot getting
into fields do you plan on doing
something like that like creating a new
vertical or do you plan on continuing
going in the content creation route and
building up a social platform like that
i think maybe both at the same time like
i'll do the content creation as long as
it's still making me a lot of money but
because i mean people like you can make
so much money doing content way more
than people would expect honestly but i
think also at the same time while using
my platform i would start a business and
build it up but it's not as easy as
people think i mean like to even promote
like a merch line and stuff like that
people people see like oh you have 1.7
mil or so on instagram like if even one
percent of your audience were to buy a
shirt then but it's not always that
simple
so yeah i think it just depends yeah
yeah uh you know you were mentioning
earlier about like car stereotypes can
you share any of those it's like the
tech people go for uh you know mclarens
and then flashy people go for the lambos
if you notice something between the car
is it can you share that oh yeah
what have you noticed yeah well i mean
you got the the classics like
rolls-royce people i never can even get
them in videos because their windows are
always up it's always a miracle if i can
film that but bentley especially rolls
royce you got the old crusty people
every time like they're crusty they're
old they don't really want to talk
sometimes they're spirited old fellas
but uh for the most part it's like
crusty white man in the in the rolls
royce um or like yeah they have a driver
or whatnot um and then you have like
bentley people they're kind of usually
like older as well they're like 60 70.
um that's pretty standard usually kind
of friendly but also kind of alongside
the rolls-royce train and then you have
um
aston martin people
more like fancy they're they're not
really like flashy so a lot of the times
the aston martin people won't want to
tell me exactly what they do but a lot
of them are like lawyers i don't know
why yeah
yeah
i know a lawyer within aston yeah me i
know a couple yeah that makes sense yeah
and they're yeah they're kind of private
normally or like businessy like in some
kind of business then you have the
mclaren people
and they're like young new money like
they're usually in tech they love
getting the crazy colors on them um and
they love whipping around rodeo drive
with their windows down ferrari is
harder to kind of
get a hand on ferrari is difficult with
like who they give cars out to like
they'll sue people all the time you
can't modify them so you normally get
like an older crowd and ferrari won't
even sell you a brand new ferrari you
have to like go through their many hoops
of uh ownership and weird rules and
signing your life away
um and then lambo people are also kind
of like mclaren people they're usually
like younger money
kind of anti-ferrari so you'll usually
be younger than ferrari people the
bugatti people are never responding to
me like i've literally gotten like maybe
one or two like bugatti chirons or
something like that in a video anything
above like a million or so they're
private people i don't know why they
come out to these car shows because like
people can see what they look like but
it's usually a never
they just they won't do it usually i've
noticed it's uh royalty
or sometimes it's something illegal
there was one there was a big
issue
years back this must have been almost 10
years ago where there was a guy who
disappeared with the bugatti and he
apparently had ties to like the
malaysian mob or mafia or like some ties
like that and he came to the u.s brought
all this money over and betrayed one of
them and then he just disappeared oh
really yeah it was a big thing in the
car community back then oh and this was
in beverly hills oh really yeah or he
was he was off oh and like oh maybe that
was it i think he was off and people
were like and and then all the rumors
started to speculate that he was
involved in something he shouldn't have
oh but there's some like crazy usually
going like that sort of
space yeah
the crazy ones it's happened to me like
i've gotten um i guess this is public
info now i don't really always talk
about it out loud i don't i think i'm
fine but um basically i got some guy in
a video in a ferrari
and he's with this like girl who's like
an israeli citizen and he's from um
syria or his dad was from syria he's
like on the fbi's most wanted list and
he's like banned from america
essentially but i get him the sun in
america i post the video they're acting
kind of weird they're like we're
students or so i'm a student and i'm
like student driving a ferrari must be
really you know i don't even know what
you say to that like you're a student um
and then everything seems fine so i post
the video and then i get like hit up by
all these organizations like and they're
like we'd like to interview about this
person that you interacted with um and
then i finally get a link to an article
because it's trending on youtube it gets
like five million views on youtube this
video i think it may be gone now
actually so i don't know what happened
there but it's like playboy billionaire
son of syrian fpi most wanted spotted in
rodeo drive with israeli girlfriend like
press like
vice news or like forbes or something
make an article and i'm like oh my gosh
i didn't know so i don't know who else
i've got you had a man he's right there
so i think he's all good i think it's
his dad who's oh my god you feel nervous
about like your own safety or anything
from that or were you fine i mean i
don't i feel like it's like a genuine i
don't know
that's why i said i haven't really
talked about it much so you guys might
be somebody i think people hear it but
uh yeah yeah it's not like he got the
guy like the fugitive himself no and the
video's already out it's not malicious
so like i would feel like if you were
out there to try to expose them then you
could be in danger but the fact that
it's a one-off thing and like you're
doing it to everybody i don't think
you're at risk it's a bad place you know
the to film a wrong place wrong time for
him i guess you could say a lot of
really wealthy families by the way will
come here and they'll take like one
class at ucla and they're a student yeah
that's what i've seen a lot a lot of
people from like dubai um
saudi arabia all get like the ballers
that are on rodeo drive and they're
driving every single time i see them
they're in a new car and it's like a lot
of royalty um so yeah that's like that's
probably like five percent of the people
i get on rodeo yeah i rented a house to
a guy like that and it was 50 000 a
month but it was just for his friends to
stay there because he rented out the
beverly hills hotel and like an entire
floor for him and his family and the
assistants and like you know all of that
but this house was next to the beverly
hills hotel for his buddies really it
was insane what they'll do is they'll
take their cars and they'll fly them
down and then they'll be able to park
them on rodeo drive or outside of the uh
the beverly wilshire hotel wow
like cargo like yeah fly them like yes
whoa okay they'll just show up one day
and the thing is they'll have like
multiple people just to drive these cars
around so they could park them all
outside of the hotel oh my gosh yeah and
then they just walk out and they'll pick
which car they want to drive it's
insane i was just there at the beverly
hills hotel like two days ago and i'm
just looking at all the cars that are
there and it's like 50 super cool yeah
what's the other one that's really good
the peninsula hotel there's basically
all those hotels there you go to the
valet and guarantee there's something
worth a million dollars there yeah nutty
it's crazy and just the amount of wealth
and and i've gone to a bunch of
different cities like miami vegas um la
are like kind of like the hot spots but
like la you get like the people that are
like really truly wealthy um and they're
just there you know beverly hills style
and then miami you'll get like the
people that are like the bitcoin um
ballers out there i call them like
they're like the new it's like the
bitcoin city now like when i go there
you got a 50 chance of running into like
a crypto bro in miami so it's super
interesting i don't know now they're
trading in the ferraris yeah speaking
about crypto have you ever tried to
ask like people in normal cars because
we know somebody the dogecoin
millionaire and he drives like this very
unsuspecting car um so have you ever for
a day tried like you know the corollas
or the previous just to see like what
you would get uh people have told me to
do it the people say do it with bad cars
sometimes that's one thing and i was
gonna do it at the beginning but now i
feel like that would come off like
really bad but i think that's an
interesting idea with like just regular
people um like regular people like
regular cars just kind of getting like
their life advice and whatnot the thing
is you'd have to ask them how much money
they make because you could find
somebody and be like i own my own
business but you don't know if it's like
you know twenty thousand dollar your
business or twenty million dollars a
year if you ask how much they make and
they're driving corolla how much you
make five million dollars a year yeah
you're driving this yeah
it's out there yeah
why waste money on a depreciating asset
yeah that's what you would need if you
could just ask them how much money do
you make yeah yeah it's like
transparency right and that's and that's
also a good way that you could always
transition instead of what do you do for
a living how many money do you make yeah
yeah i don't i just i think it depends
on who you get some people might be like
get out of my face very rude but
something the irs no literally people
say i'm like an undercover irs operative
i don't know if i've ever exposed i bet
you have i'm sure like okay you're being
audited well you were in this viral
video of you driving a lamborghini like
where did you claim your job yeah
exactly yeah tax returns just ten
thousand dollars a year
i've ruined thousands of lives yeah you
could have so how have you been able to
turn this into a business because i'm
i'm seeing some people off camera here
and uh how much is involved behind the
scenes to do this i mean there's a
couple layers i keep it so i have my
agent stephen he's over here shout out
steven uh he helps me do brand deals so
anytime i so i guess i'm like my own
manager stevens the agent so a lot of
like tick tock people will have like
their own manager completely and they'll
handle like their email like their day
to day stuff like that so like i'll
still get like inbound emails to my
email take a look at it whatever um i'll
pass it along to stephen he will do all
the negotiating and forgive me if i
butcher some of what you do but he's the
negotiation man like before when i was
without steven um who works at caa
they're one of the biggest um firms in
the world huge yeah yeah they're the
biggest maybe i think yeah um they i i
would be negotiating myself and i'd be
like oh you know way undercutting myself
like my first couple brand deals i was
doing was like
five thousand dollars 15 or like 10 000
stuff like that and it was like just was
way low this is right when i was first
starting out like with my account so i
had a couple million but still like
getting sizable view amounts um so then
steven will like negotiate with um you
know the brand they'll uh you know
basically try to up it to whatever we're
comfortable with a lot of the legal on
the background is huge
all the fine tuning of documents and
redlining and stuff like that it's back
and forth for like sometimes up to
months and whatnot um and meeting with
the people you know you're facetiming
with them or webex things excuse me um
setting up what the video idea will be
making a script so sometimes i'll jump
in there and once uh the deal has been
set and all the other stuff i'm
forgetting about is done then i'll make
a script and then that'll go through
redlining and approval and then once
that's done then you finally can shoot
and then there's the edits after the
shooting and there's always a million of
them and blake over here is my producer
and basically once you shoot the video
and we think it's good we always think
it's good and we make it our style
brands have certain tastes and they you
know want it to be perfect to what they
want to do for their marketing so we'll
go back and forth sometimes like five or
six times you know with different edits
and then that's when the video is posted
yeah give us an example of a brand how
do you integrate a brand and what do you
do for a living i mean it's nice because
it's such a broad topic so like what do
you do for a living could be associated
with like any brand like i could go up
to someone in a car and they could be a
representative of the brand or like i've
gone up to like bmw for example i did a
video with and they had a brand new
electric car that we shot with and they
have a professional bmw driver in the
car he's like get in man like let me
show you the the car i'm a race car
driver so you can like you can use
pretty much any occupation it's so broad
and i didn't realize how good it was
when i made it i just i just you know
essentially filmed the video but it
works for pretty much any that's true
think about that yeah i've seen those
videos
yeah um that's interest that's a good
spin on it i really like that it's just
so bright it's like i didn't realize how
good it was for how broad it is yeah i
got lucky with it i guess you could say
yeah and walk us through like an average
day how many hours do you work what do
you work on i work more than people
would expect i think people with tick
talkers like they say you know you're
not just doing the dances in front of
the camera like i hopefully will never
have to do a dance in my life but um
i'll wake up in the morning normally i'm
a night owl though so sometimes people
will be like oh you wake up at 10 30.
like you're lazy but i stay up until
like three or four sometimes like
working so my whole schedule's a little
shifted but usually i'll wake up like 10
10 30 or so um
i'll check my email normally first um
steven and i will hop on a call and
we'll be discussing like what a brand
wants or you know we'll be reaching out
to brands or they'll be reaching out to
us
i'll usually start filming something
during the day like weekends are my film
days so i'll go out to like a car show
go to rodeo wait around for like six
hours for something interesting to
happen um if i'm not filming like an ad
or doing um tracking people down like
literally on the street um then we'll be
like editing videos or
you know posting is really what takes up
all my time like i manage five platforms
and i do i post everything myself so
like i'll wake up in the morning and say
i have one video i'll basically stack
the videos in order of what makes the
most money so snapchat will be first
like you'll see everything on snapchat a
week prior to anything else and then
facebook jack hear that yeah snapchat
snapchat's where it's at um i don't want
people to see it on tiktok and then skip
away from snapchat so it's kind of like
a funnel of snapchat
facebook reels which is newer um
and then youtube and tick tock and then
instagram last because they don't have
me in their reels fun so thanks a lot
you're not in the realz fund no i'm even
in the realz fund
i they don't i haven't posted reels
that's the crazy thing they just they
never invited me i think because i post
every day they're like why give them
money so it's super screwed up i don't
have an instagram rep but um
so instagram's on the bottom and then
basically all day long i'll be like i'll
go through all five of those and also
i'll post five posts a day so you're
getting the captions you're replying to
people to get engagement up um and all
that stuff promoting it on your stories
that's what takes up like 40 of my day
is just getting all these posts on and
then monitoring them commenting to them
um and making the thumbnails and all
that stuff so you've got this down to a
science now like what to post do the
captions matter that much i'd say so um
oh captions on screen yeah oh for sure
no no i mean the captions on like uh
like below an instagram post or with a
description oh yeah the actual yeah um
yeah i'd say so i i think it's i think
it's important you know but i wouldn't
say it's like the end-all be-all um i
think hashtags also aren't that
important i don't know if it helps too
much with like i don't know i mean i
feel like you know for youtube more than
me but my number one recommendation to
people is captions on screen that aren't
auto generated but like moving around
stimulated and fast cuts yeah can you
share how much money you're making i can
give you like a rough estimate okay um
i'd say it depends on what's going on
with like brand deals and stuff like
that um but and some months are
different than others but like on
snapchat and that's my primary um income
source some months can be like 15 000
only some months can be like 60 000 per
month um and then
reels has a new facebook reels fund
where you can cap out at 35k a month so
i can't get that now like they used to
make it like 50 million views would be
the cap and now it's like 150 or 200
million views so that was good for like
a month or two while it lasted but um
reels i can make like roughly well it
just depends now but you know around 10
20 000 10 000 i'd say now
um and then brand deals can be you know
i don't want to give too much info on
that but they're just a rough estimate
around that front so yeah so what would
you expect over the course of a year
just like an average year what do you
think that would equate to through
everything
i'd say
it depends like because the thing is
last year is was the big blowout year
for me and this year's uh different you
know it's it's like more money in
different uh areas but as far as like ad
revenue goes it's kind of been going
down a little bit it goes through like
phases um but definitely you know mid
six figures um i'd say is probably
standard for like a year to year basis
yeah that's fantastic yeah i think you
need to be expanding this yeah yeah i i
get so worried but i'm so like
pessimistic when it comes to like all
things social media for me it's like
last month i gotta make it good i worry
that like
beyond another year or two you gotta
figure out a shift
i think the podcast man could make you
so much money i agree with you
on the podcast yeah five to ten minutes
enough where you could because uh didn't
tick tock have like the 10 minute limit
now uh yeah 10 minutes yeah but i think
you did like five ten minute interviews
yeah you know not a full podcast like
this five ten minutes post on facebook
where like i'm curious where so on
youtube for sure yeah youtube uh tick
tock if they do or tick tock you even
just do three minutes the snapchat tiles
would be good yeah that and facebook
yeah yeah i think just repurposing
whatever did you film vertical for all
that in vertical and horizontal so you
probably
yeah you would have to i wish they'd
make a phone i've been telling it apple
you know not really my direct line to
you know mr apple but um why don't they
have a phone that has the ability to
record in vertical and horizontal at the
same time it would be great that's a you
know what's really good why is that a
thing
what's that
what why like that's it that's something
for me
that's a problem everyone has had it's
insane i don't know why it's not a thing
and i don't even know if people i'm sure
people have thought of it like that's
like a genius idea i'm like yeah that's
one of those ideas where it's just like
why didn't i think of that you could do
a patreon
yeah you could do a patreon and then
release early on patreon or you can
release the interviews on the page you
could you could have only fans girls on
there what do you do for a living let me
show you yeah
only on patreon
what
i don't know the patreon people tell me
to do it and they reached out to me like
patreon specifically and they're like
why don't you have one but i don't know
i just i hate promoting it i don't know
he i hate promoting a lot of stuff and i
feel like i should just get better you
got to get better at it i just like i
it's so crin to me like i was kind of
shy starting out with my account so i
didn't show my face something to me just
would get like what up y'all subscribe
to my patreon i know like everyone does
it i just like gotta get better at doing
and people will want to support you
would be happy to do it yeah i would say
probably ninety percent of people don't
care
eight percent of people do it's mutually
beneficial it's like you're providing
value to these people in the same way
that they're providing value to you um
okay it's an interesting way you're
looking at it yeah yeah i mean it makes
sense you know early access to videos
yeah if i really liked someone i would
be like sure i'll pay for that if you
already tapped out and how much you can
work you can hire someone else out
that's overhead and the patreon can help
pay for that you can produce more with
the patreon as well which is awesome
yeah let's talk about different
platforms and where you think the most
valuable platform like which one is it
and if you were to rank them on having a
presence how would you go from like
number one to like number five well it
depends on what kind of content you make
so like if you make short form content
uh well and i know it's different for
you you do long form content so like at
least on youtube we do clips on tick
tock okay yeah so tick tock pays i'll
tell you exactly how much tick tock pays
i mean you guys probably know too but
twenty dollars to thirty dollars per
million views which is awful like you'll
literally have a video with 10 million
views and an ad revenue you know you're
making nothing so i'd say as far as like
money but then you're getting all the
brand deals as well so like tick tock to
me
is if it were if i weren't getting brand
deals through tick-tock and it wasn't my
biggest platform i would be like screw
tick tock it's on the bottom i'm posting
it last so it's all about the brand
deals so i keep that in mind because
instagram i'm doing brand deals as well
and they don't pay me anything but i
still beef it up and post on there as
well but as far as like snapchat to me
isn't the best platform but i post like
compilation videos and i don't think i
don't see it being around though forever
like it sort of could be dying
so i i don't know where to rate it there
but i'd say youtube has their stuff
together they are kind of ahead of the
game on the shorts field of stuff you
know like they're competing with tick
tock now much better and now they have a
bonus fund as well so i think youtube's
obviously gonna be there forever to stay
um facebook's the sleeper pick though
i'd say like people in in america at
least like globally everyone uses
facebook two billion users a year a day
or a month or whatever and people at
least you know that i talk to are like
why would you get a facebook but that's
where you make so much money like people
like super car blondie for example you
know yeah she's huge on facebook yeah i
was talking to her she's like this is by
far our biggest platform to make money
on and they you know you post three to
four minute videos you can do two ads on
a four minute video or so and no one is
thinking about it i mean obviously
people internationally are but for some
reason in my generation at least it's
like facebook's dead but like money-wise
facebook is not dead and i was late to
it anyways the thing is i think the uh
the people with money to spend are on
facebook because they tend to be a
little bit older and they have the
discretionary income versus some of the
other platforms they're so young that
it's harder to target them for ads yeah
facebook's the best apparently yeah for
ad like ad targeting i mean evidence
caused a little bit of problems i just i
just tried uh doing facebook again by
the way remember i was doing that i did
that really so six months yourself no no
there's another company who did it but
um yeah so i did facebook post uh
reposting my videos from the main
channel and like little compilation
clips and whatnot on facebook for six
months did nothing at all and yeah but
your videos were like 10 to 12 minutes
right no no no no they cut them down
they caught them now they caught them
yeah they they fully edited the videos
and uh we had a talk and we were both
very honest they said we just don't
think your content is working for this
um it you know facebook tends to be an
older demographic a lot of it is
international and your your videos are
very focused to younger u.s
audience
and um it turned out
then i stopped in january turns out that
just like out of nowhere it started
getting traction and it was getting like
10 to 20 000 views a day on facebook
just randomly so i'm starting it back up
yeah see what happens huh i mean yeah
it's so it was so weird but i've heard
good things about facebook yeah yeah i
have a big international like
international is huge for me i think
america is only like 20 percent of my
audience they're 25. that's barely the
majority um and then older too like my
demographics like my top demographic is
like 25 to 35 and then 35 to 45 or so is
almost the same as 18 to 25 which is
really interesting but i think it's
because older people are into cars too i
can see that yeah and also your content
is watchable just no matter where you
are in the world do you do different
languages uh yeah oh like as far as like
subs yeah so either subtitles or
voiceovers like mr beast is doing like
mr beast and spanish and like
have you thought about doing that you
could just repurpose their companies
yeah we've talked to a couple some of
them were really sketchy like uh they're
really always sketchy the ones so we
need to find like a legit one because i
brought it up and i've been like well
they do it all for you but it's like the
messages are sketchy they want like your
payment and it's just i know legit one
okay yes all right you got it you got to
hook it up afterwards yeah we could do
that for for our podcast too just do
everything in a different light it would
be so difficult just imagine
transcribing that
for the entire podcast i think he also
believe it or not has like a a company
or something or he has a partnership
with a company that does that as well oh
yeah i think so i don't quote me on that
but yeah he was talking to joe rogan or
something like that about that yeah
yeah i think he was listening to that
podcast like two days ago so good
podcast he makes so much money doing
that too it's like why didn't other
people do that but i guess he's kind of
leading the yeah yeah yeah that's
something i would never even think of
but now that he's doing it makes sense
yeah so easy too yeah you really don't
do anything right yeah so one other
thing i want to talk about is it seems
like you're a master at getting on every
platform and blowing up on every
platform what are some of the strategies
or things that you've changed in your
own content creation style that have
like tremendously affected your your
trajectory yeah i mean some of them are
like kind of basic that you would expect
like i would say obviously number one
and especially for short form i'd say
i'm like the master of short form long
form i still haven't mastered completely
we need to look to you guys on that one
but for short form
i mean if you just watch someone on tick
tock like watch them scroll you people
say you have three seconds to hook
someone you have like literally point
two seconds so someone like it needs to
be in the so on my videos like cha-ching
pops up you're like it's like
stimulating the captions are bouncing on
the screen and moving around like i
would not use like auto generated text
at least for short form and i'm going to
speak to tick tock as i would to like
youtube shorts and all that it's kind of
all the same but um essentially yeah you
got to hook them like faster than you'd
expect like there can't even be
any lag time is what i call it between
any portions of the video on any short
form i used to when i started out i
think it was because it was a new trend
i had a like more leeway and in pauses
and whatnot but now when i shoot videos
like this if someone just says like um
that's chopped now it's really like boom
boom boom like so stimulating like we
call it like crack video is what can i
call i'm like make it more cracked yeah
and we'll be like okay this is cracked
now so that's how you know a video is
like gonna do well as if it's like crazy
stimulating or you cut it early um and
then as far as i just tell everyone to
post on all platforms like people are
like i'm not on facebook because i'm
like why like get your same short form
video post it on shorts post it on reels
post on snapchat um and then be
consistent as well like people say to do
that a lot but i post every single day
or every other day um and i wouldn't
have more than like a week or so break
and you know maybe take a break for
whatnot but i'll schedule stuff in
advance so there isn't a big gap does
that worry you
about people's attention spans being
like just turned to mush yeah
it's already happening i think because
of tick-tock i i can't people can barely
sit through long-form videos a lot of
the times now in some circumstances
because they're like i need i need more
simulation dying breed jack yeah
seriously we could we i i have a feeling
we're a dying breed a podcast
is going to be attention spans i don't
know i i'm actually extremely bullish on
podcasts in the same way because you
could clip them up
no it's because because
it's like competitors are music because
it's for people that are in the gym
they're driving to work or they're like
you know traveling that's when you
listen to podcasts and we're not
competing with youtube metallica
i don't sit down and watch podcasts the
only time i list the podcast quite often
but it's when i'm driving or when i'm
working out and there's i'm not going to
be scrolling on tick tock whenever
you'll be funny yeah comment comment if
you guys are at the gym right now
watching this seriously just comment and
be like yep graham i'm at the gym right
now don't comment if you're driving no
just pull over on this pull over and
right now and say i'm driving right now
you're right yeah because yeah i only
listen to podcasts when i'm driving
around an airplane so we're not
competing with like tick tock and stuff
which that that's the reason why i'm
super bullish on podcasts yeah that
makes total sense yeah but here's the
thing is that uh you know people are
getting older
gen z is coming up right now yeah and
their attention spans for like a minute
you know so like self-driving cars so
eventually
so eventually
that minute is going to take over it's
going to be just everything you watch
could be like minute minute minute
minute minute everything you're going to
go on tv
or not even watch tv but like your your
tv is basically going to be like three
second clips
yeah
have you seen the videos uh going over
like the tick tock conspiracies of like
you know how it how it is here versus
like overseas have you seen some of
those no i don't think so okay pull me
in yeah apparently oh and this is a what
jack i'm going i didn't say anything
yeah go and watch any of the videos that
say like tick tock is the most evil app
ever now i listen i i like listen i'm
going with an open mind but apparently
they show different content here than
they do elsewhere oh and uh
yeah try to dumb us down in china it's
like right it's like they're learning
about how to create you know
very like very inspirational uplifting
stories and here we get like lip-syncing
dances yeah just like just yeah like
nothing much
yeah they're educating them it's like
only educational content is like praised
over there yeah and over here it's like
shut down yeah they're getting very
strict by the way in toronto about
influencers they ran a story in cnbc i
think it was last night it says now
influencers have to have proven
qualifications if they are to talk about
certain subjects no gurus no gurus
anymore so
so i would not i would not have a career
there uh but yeah they want you to be
licensed with the proper credentials to
be able to talk about certain topics uh
and with that also they said that they
did not want any flashing of luxury
goods a luxury lifestyle or anything
that was extravagant or wasteful
including by the way wasting food
was something that they specified in
that wow it was very interesting it was
done by like the government yeah wow
yeah and then it was also no live
streaming after 10 p.m it was like no
watching live streams until after until
you know after 10 p.m live streams to me
or well if you've been on the tick tock
live stream yeah it is like a nightmare
it's way worse than snapchat discover
page thumbnails go it's like you're
seeing the bottom of society essentially
on purpose though like
it sounds bad they're literally like
it sounds basically these people are
like they're doing the weirdest stuff on
purpose just to keep you watching oh do
you remember when they used to have like
a bowl of worms and they'd be like
they'd spoon the worms and this is on
the live streams because you'd see it
and they'd be like all right i'm going
to eat it and then they'd do that for 30
minutes and they wouldn't eat it and
people like one more donation and i'll
eat it and then people go in and out and
they don't say oh you're not eating it
or some people will oh because they tune
out click on it and you're like oh this
guy's just about to take a bite of these
but he just leaves it there and you
would never eat it and i remember dude
there was this one how long were you on
there jack how much did you donate you
were there
the actual eat yeah no no no no no no no
i was on this one guys for 20 minutes
i'm not kidding because i was like
getting ready for bed so i was like
brushing my teeth you know doing my
thing and um and he just kept saying he
was going to eat it but he wasn't and he
had like lots of years like ten thousand
viewers at that time making money and
then all of a sudden out of nowhere the
live ended
so yeah
so he didn't eat the worms and i
remember i commented on his latest um
this is actually really bad i found it
on his latest tick tock after he went
off of live and i was like i was like um
i said something like like you're a sham
like you'll never find love
no something like basically i was just
like hating on him you know i should
have like in the world i was like why
would you do what you do like you're
taking people's attention for your own
monetary gain and providing no value
whatsoever
talk though i mean let's be real
like they're peeling eggs that go on
forever sometimes they're on loops oh
the egg peeling yeah oh my gosh
yes i've watched that way too much but
the story the guy got back feeling
because he said he saw the comment and
he got back to me usually he was like
what did i do to you
and i said you know what you did and
then that was where why did he what if
he doesn't what if he could change his
whole what if his wife my entire you
know his entire thing was the wormy what
if his wi-fi cut out the moment he took
a bite and he's like oh damn he all cut
out he's just like you know he needs to
change careers yeah you could talk to
him maybe yeah change him yeah yeah the
algorithm
my issue is that the algorithm i think
is very dangerous and it gets you into
this echo chamber where it'll it could
lead you in a direction where all of a
sudden that's all you get and it's
that's your only viewpoint it's just
based on that and the algorithm is so
good at figuring out what that is
that within like three minutes already
knows so much about you and what to show
you yeah that's why but it's effective
so well yeah i mean they'll people think
just because you like a video that's the
only way to do it but like they're
measuring watch time interactions
obviously you go to the comments more
and that's why tick tock killed the game
like their algorithm i had zero
followers when i first made my account
obviously and on youtube at least at the
time before shorts existed if you had
zero subscribers you wouldn't be able to
just post a long form and it could like
it wouldn't get any views but like tick
tock killed it at the beginning because
i had one and it got shown to like three
people or so i think probably a certain
percentage liked it like one or two
percent then it just snowballed and now
they're all doing it as well but yeah it
kind of changed the game like they you
know like them or not they they
definitely changed it all so what would
you do if someone is starting off today
like what would your advice be to them i
think you need to try i think you need
to find a niche and it's super important
honestly like you can get viral by doing
a lot of like cool ideas and whatnot but
like you need to have like your
demographic and like niche of people
that come for your just your type of
videos so like mine's like cars and
luxury and whatnot like finance like
stuff like that but um i'd say like
throwing stuff at the wall until you see
something that you're experimenting with
that works and then it you know just
literally doing that again and again um
is the best way to at least blow up and
then you got to obviously evolve or
people you know you could just be a
trend but you got to try a bunch of
different ideas and just keep posting
them eventually maybe something will
work um and then you just run with that
idea um but hopefully it's not just like
a trend like you want to find like uh
you know some type of
video that isn't just a trend that will
last for a week is there a topic that
you want to do that you haven't done yet
uh topic or something that you're not
going to do but
you know it's a good idea uh i mean that
one we mentioned earlier i do i would
like to go to people in really bad cars
like really beating down cars uh so
that's definitely one of them but that
would give me a lot of flack i think
like brands and whatnot um
and then there's some sketches that
we've we've done that you know we've
decided are probably not brand friendly
because you always got to kind of keep
up you know you don't want to be doing
some crazy stuff but there's some
sketches and stuff that i'd like to do
they're a little off the wall because
what
my sense of humor is just like really
screwed up so like
some of the video ideas i have are just
like it wouldn't fly um i mean just for
tick tock for example like hyper
violence like but it's a sketch like
where you're just like i was like i was
thinking you could be like like only
fans sort of like i thought we were
going that direction oh no no not like
obsessed with violence either but just
like sketches where you're just like
doing ridiculous stuff you can't have
like a gun in a tank top buy a car going
like a house yeah like that yes exactly
yeah i get like run over in a video or
something like that it's happening some
guy hit me and ran while i was filming a
video one time actually did you post it
no i was in a nice car he was well no i
was filming a video in miami and i was
running to the road i like risked my
life all the time you know risked my
life but basically i'm like if i see a
bugatti i'm weaving through traffic to
go get this thing but uh one car in
miami nicked me basically was going like
70 past me and just like completely
decided like swerve around me hit me
like just lightly on the back but like
if i was this much further back would
have been like dead and then they run
their plates because we call the police
or like this guy hit you know hit and
ran turns out it was a stolen vehicle
and this person was like on the run so
wow luckily i didn't you know actually
holy cow but yeah but uh yeah i'd say um
to your point
uh some like stuff like that in the only
fan sphere and stuff like that we try to
stay away from it now yeah you know
there's only so many only fans people
you can run up to in la as well
before it's kind of like uh people are
tired of that yeah do you have anyone
signing a release
no i usually get permission though like
i mean or it's like accepted like once
i'm done like hey man thanks so much and
they're like after i cut you know i'll
cut the videos early and they'll be like
oh no problem like yeah you know it is
kind of an issue you film it when they
say it's funny you should oh i have it
yeah so i'll cut the videos on tick tock
oh yeah or you know the short form you
know crack or whatnot but um yeah
exactly i feel like someone at some
point could
it's a whole weird thing though like in
public i can film someone i talk to my
lawyers and they're like yeah you can
film if you're profiting off of it it's
you know
yeah all about that no i don't all it's
going to take though is one viral video
with someone who's like a public figure
who is maybe running from the law or
like something like that or maybe like
you're going to catch them with like a
mistress or something like that in the
car it's going to go viral
that's happened yeah yeah one guy this
is a short story one guy in dallas my
first couple times filming he um he was
getting in a car with some like
good-looking woman and he was in a suit
i got him in a video and on camera he
goes you're the guy that uh and then he
just completely changed his character
he's like dude man like i'll let you
drive my ferrari i'll let you do
whatever please don't post the video i'm
not supposed to be here
but and i'm like oh god and he's like
dude you can do whatever you can drive
my car he's like begging me and i was
like oh gosh okay i won't post this
assumed it was because of a mistress
yeah well he was with another woman next
to him so i mean come on you know
well he could be in some legal trouble
as well maybe uh there could be a
multitude of things on it i don't think
it has to just be that i'd say that's a
50 50 on that but it doesn't have to
yeah yeah but i have a feeling it's
going to be a situation like that where
they don't think anything of it they
probably don't know who you are and
they're like you know some some kid is
just coming up to me it goes viral and
they're like well i didn't consent to
that yeah uh i would highly recommend if
you don't already have media insurance
do you no get it media immediately what
does that do so what it does is it it it
protects you in the event of a lawsuit
and especially normally i'm like you
never need media insurance but for you
i'd highly recommend it okay in the
event someone sues you for something
um
you will be covered
and it basically yeah so like i had you
know i have one that i just feel just
gives me peace of mind it's worth it
it's probably gonna cost you
20 grand a year 25 grand a year but i
that that is going to pay for even a
lawyer lawyer's retainer like right off
the bat if something were to happen with
the amount of views that you're getting
it's probably going to be fine but like
one case
especially with people with money
they could afford to basically just
bankrupt you okay yeah just uh you do
any damage to them uh you know even
unintentional
they could sue you for damage okay even
even if they won't win but like for like
a whole like
lawsuit
you could you could
uh select your tears so you'd be like i
want to be covered up to five million or
10 million
oh so you get that much of potential
coverage wow yeah okay my worry is that
you do something to somebody and they
just want to run you to the ground like
let's say you caught someone with a
mistress or or you you catch someone
smoking let's just say and like that
that's bad for their image they lose a
whole bunch of business um they don't
think anything of it comes down they
lose a deal and they come to you and say
i'm going to sue you let's just say they
have no grounds to do that but if they
have money they could just say well you
know what uh fight me in court and and
then it's a battle of who has uh more
money oh interest yeah and you'll lose
to
you know well or even if you win then
you have to counter sue and you have to
spend even more money to get your money
back it's a nightmare so i think just be
insured i think that's media insurance
so media insurance i think you're right
tom like that's how i do it
it's good peace of mind and it's a
write-off hopefully you will never need
it okay but i have the same thing and
it's worth it it's just peace of mind
that's all okay what questions do you
have for us we could we could turn this
around if you want to if you have any
questions uh for jack and i well i'm
curious like on i'll go revenue on you
guys too actually um how much do you
make graham stefan for the whole year uh
it's this year is going to be between
probably four and six before okay yeah
are you investing all that money in the
market right now pretty much um
i mean the default is always to save it
so it's uh inflation though no not
necessarily because i i like to to keep
cash on hand for opportunities to come
up or like if something if if there's a
good opportunity it helps to have the
cash on hand you're buying right now
into the like oh yeah oh absolutely yeah
every day okay yeah i've been doing that
for uh over two years now so just like
every day i just buy into the market
yeah on a regular basis yeah so are you
at what point i just want to take a
guess here what do you and no one can
know obviously but where do you think
the market's gonna bottom out your s p
500 percentage-wise i have no clue i
mean everyone's everyone's calling for
like i don't know as a guess
yeah man uh
it's gonna be a coin toss i mean my
guess i i would not be surprised if the
s p gets to like 3 000 maybe 32 like
somewhere around there okay um wouldn't
be surprised um i think i think it's
possible but i think it's also possible
that inflation starts coming down and
they stop raising rates as much are you
investing two yeah generally and like
you don't want to know about okay yeah
what is your what is your portfolio
looking like uh like as far as like
assets like yeah yeah
well uh crypto was probably 10 now it's
probably like one uh
where were you in were you in like some
[ __ ] no no it's just like bitcoin
ethereum but it's probably not one
anymore but the secret jackpot of crypto
yeah
4000 theories everything
like because like i'm 5k
no no actually bitcoin wasn't that bad
my average cost on bitcoin was probably
like 40 or like 30. okay you know it was
probably like 30 35. kind of similar too
yeah yeah and then as far as like the
market uh i actually had pretty good
average cost before
december because in december i like just
piled everything and i was like you know
what's the end of the year i have two
like a bunch of change so i just went
all in terrible terrible terrible
mistake but we live and learn you know
dollar cost averaging is the way to go
apparently well i don't know i've read
about lump sum that
you get lucky or you don't and the thing
is for me i put in so much money in the
market between november and right up to
the very first of the year literally me
too
i have a lot of money now and i was like
here we go very conservative like s p
500 like and then like apple google like
you know like i wasn't buying anything i
bought like if i buy like a bad stock
what i consider to be like a you know
not fancy stuff like lucid motors or
something like that a little bit of a
gamble it's like a couple thousand but i
was like oh i'm good smb so i'm not
selling so i know i'll be fine but
december me too yeah it was literally
like yeah i had literally no money yeah
i had no money
that's so funny yeah it completely
obliterated me you know we live and we
learn yeah and we'll be fine
but i was also probably a little bit
more speculative than you were like i
had um i had a portfolio of my robin
hood portfolio and i think my principal
in that was like like 20 grand or
something like that and i brought it all
the way up to 75 because i was investing
like pretty early and uh and then once i
hit 75 it was probably at right around
65 actually i just went all in a margin
oh
because like
most of the margin though that i bought
was like it was like apple stock it was
like pretty safe margin it wasn't like
sketchy stuff what's the rate on that
for your margin i was probably five
percent no it's probably last it's
probably i don't know what robin hood is
maybe three and a half four oh yeah yeah
i don't know what it is but at the time
that you were borrowing i think it was
at like 2.9 uh okay so that now like
yeah i don't know
but i got completely obliterated like
like that but then again you know they
they do the whole margin call thing you
know that whole thing happens but yeah
that wasn't doing to people on the phone
no you weren't calling yeah yeah were
you really schwab yeah margin call
people all the time i mean you notify
them and it's horrifying for them it's
kind of sad but also you're like whoa
like yeah this person's crazy risk bet
that they just did and what do you say
what do you see on that like do you look
at their you obviously see their
investments like yeah do you see stupid
things that they're going on there i
mean well and at the beginning you're
kind of just like a phone slave when
you're first starting out in this
program um
you know but basically they'd call in
and you get some people on like on the
line that would just be so rude and
really rich and some of them would have
crazy like ninety percent in one stock
like they'd be like have a million
dollar portfolio and it's like all in
lucid or like all in tesla which worked
out for them maybe at the time but a lot
of tesla people like literally like uh
four you know 40 of their portfolio is
in tesla and they're just like whoa like
what are you doing but they're just all
doing it themselves i don't know see
robin hood did not call me they just
sent me a little thing oh you're in a
margin call we're selling your shares
automatically so it wasn't i don't know
what exactly what it was like um i know
we just like you do notifications and
whatnot um but you had to be a broker to
actually
call in and like or be discussing
directly with them what i was doing
because i wasn't i didn't get all my set
i didn't get my seven basically in my
series seven so i literally left right
before i was about to take it so like
i'd basically be interacting with people
that would like call in and be like hey
what's going on with this why do i have
a margin call and i'd be like oh um it's
not good but uh here's a broker do this
or whatever yeah until you're further
along what do you think of tesla stock i
think it's overvalued like i think it's
way overvalued but i was tired it's kind
of like bitcoin i was tired of just it
going up i don't see it as like at this
buying point as something that i would
maybe long term you know but
i think it was i knew it was going to
correct and i don't think its correction
now is as far as it could go just based
off of like its market cap for the
amount that they're selling it's worth
more than all of the other automakers
combined combined it's insane like it
doesn't matter if you believe that
they're gonna do other stuff and i'm
sure they're you know they're doing
other stuff that isn't just cars i know
they are but like it's still overvalued
i think so i think if it hasn't happened
completely yet it'll go down and still
go up but not yeah when i bought the
roadster i sold off uh a decent chunk of
my tesla stock at one thousand twenty
eight dollars a share whoa
wow yeah thank you so thankful on that
and then i sold
shortly after because once you start
selling you're like well sell more
uh so i sold off all but 100 grand in my
tesla stock oh wow okay well yeah that's
so we'll see we'll see what happens but
man what's up you're a little swing
trader no that's that's something i've
i've hel i've held on to that for three
years long swing three or four yeah
three and a half years
no no but i'm also gonna be selling some
losing positions to offset that so i'm
not going to own any tax on that but and
then i took the money and i just put it
in the s p and an international index
fund okay can you only write off 3 000
and
no that's against personal income so you
could offset
uh let's say long-term capital gains
against losses so let's just say i make
a hundred grand in tesla stock but i
lost 100 grand in uh let's just say
coinbase
now i don't have to pay any tax because
i've used the gain to offs or i've used
the loss to offset the gain now if i
didn't have any gains to offset you
could write off up to three thousand
dollars a year against your personal
income okay so that yeah so if you're
double u-two you're making a hundred
grand uh you could write off three
thousand dollars of that okay gotcha per
you make sure you did that right yeah
per year or you spread it across but but
it doesn't make any sense to me because
that number should be adjusted for
inflation and i think it should be
higher yeah for sure i mean what is that
useful for at all i mean i guess unless
for i don't know it depends on your
income level but like three grand
in the
scheme of things like depending on if
you're doing like a wash sale and stuff
like that it's just like i don't think i
think they need to make it higher some
people are losing big i know well thank
you so much for coming on i really
appreciate it uh the one thing i would
recommend you do is to get your free
stock down below in the description when
you sign up for public using the code
gram it's worth all the way up to a
thousand dollars and you could add jls
selby on instagram good point
uh and we can alexander podcast
underscore
that's it yeah thanks guys
we have a tier on patreon it's 500 a
month but what that gets is uh twice a
year we're gonna be hosting a private
event where this person can come down
we'll be hosting uh you know food drinks
all the good stuff they could come down
and just hang with us for the night and
just just chat just have a good time hey
uh rick you are on the podcast with uh
myself graham jack daniel mack and uh
alex how's it going
hey you're doing good
so
so okay so uh first of all we just
wanted to call and thank you for the uh
for the patreon we just put this up and
uh jack was like dude we go we got
someone we
were the first person we got one we got
one and so i wanted i wanted to
personally call and thank you and see uh
what made you do it um well yeah i mean
i've uh i mean i kind of like
mentioned on the message like uh
i found you guys probably like the
beginning of this year and i've been an
avid listener i've listened to pretty
much all your podcasts since then
and i've just enjoyed the show and was
like heck
might as well
oh my gosh well thank you so much man i
really appreciate it do you want to
shout anything out really quick we'll
give you a free shout out
and yeah like an instagram like an
instagram there's got to be something
no i don't even have an intro rick
thomas shout me out tell him to follow
me on instagram nick we're excited to
meet you in person
i have i have just started a company um
working to um cure rare diseases called
uh everloom bio
so um i'll shout that out oh my gosh man
come on man well well here's the deal
this is uh you have my cell phone number
this is it uh if there's anything you
need just feel free to shoot a text i
get a lot of text so if if you don't get
a response back uh just just maybe text
again but anyway we're looking forward
to meeting you we'll we'll keep you
updated probably in the next few months
on hosting some event in las vegas but i
really appreciate it and are you cool if
we include this in the podcast yeah yeah
totally do it
all right
thank you so much man i really
appreciate it and uh you're on the
contacts now
all right i'll see you guys later bye
what is look at that
that is so rare diseases say god you got
something yeah so if you're training
cancer want to be like rick meet us in
person get a shout out and also meet
rick because you guys
want to meet i want to meet rick
if you want to be like rick
our patreon is down below in the
description thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
we had the best